well Brian this Saturday there's going
to be a big fundraiser for the Little
Miss Hannah Foundation now the Vegas
nonprofit helps medically fragile
children with specialized equipment and
resources as Kirsten Joyce reports your
participation in your donations help
these families year round
the Little Miss Hannah foundation's
mission is to enhance the quality of
life for young children diagnosed with
rare life-limiting medical needs they've
helped create awareness and advocacy for
children in our local community who have
rare genetic disorders like our daughter
six-year-old Sloan who loves music books
and her puppy she'll be one of the VIP
kids this weekend's Vegas cares about
rare 5K at Cornerstone Park her family
received a specialty chair from the
non-profit as the foundation provides
medical equipment for kids that would
not be covered by insurance it's great
because our daughter can do her speech
therapy and her occupational therapy in
it as well as sitting her upright so she
can do her feedings both through her
feeding tube and orally Robert and
Carrie Australia started the foundation
in their daughter Hannah's honor she was
born with a rare medical condition at
age three she passed away her Legacy
lives on through the foundation and care
provided to many other Southern Nevada
families it seems like the word is
really getting out now with different
and um
pediatric hospice centers and palliative
care and different social workers
physical therapists they're really
helping to spread the word and we're
very thankful for all the new families
that are joining
so remember families can apply for
medical equipment from the foundation
once a year the registration by the way
for this Saturday's race closes on
Thursday which is tomorrow so you can
show up the day of registration to also
apply but it's going to probably be a
little crowd